all right um buckle up everybody i'm
about to
be called a racist unfortunately there
are people who are going to listen to
this segment and call me a racist
and that's sad but i encourage you to
listen to this entire segment all the
way through
i've been telling you all along that
when joe biden does things that i don't
like
or that fail to be truly left i'm going
to point them out to you
i'm going to call them out and we have
the perfect prototypical example today
president-elect joe biden has selected
lloyd austin to be a secretary of
defense
lloyd austin is a retired four-star army
general
was previously the commander of centcom
actually was the first
african-american commander of centcom
and would be the first
african-american secretary of defense in
american history
very interesting personal story from
alabama
raised in georgia graduated from west
point two master's degrees including an
mba
really interesting guy no shortage of
intelligence no shortage of military and
other experience and academic experience
no doubt whatsoever but this is the
perfect example
of how a lot of people are focusing on
the identity story
at the exclusion of admitting and
recognizing that lloyd austin
as interesting as his career has been as
inspiring as i admit
being the first black secretary of
defense would be
lloyd austin represents exactly the
problems we're trying to fix
in government and in foreign policy and
in defense
lloyd austin is the prototypical example
of diversification in terms of identity
without changing any of the power
structures
which partially are responsible for the
problems that make his identity as the
first black secretary of defense
notable in the first place to start with
this is
another military guy who hasn't even
been out of the military long enough
seven years such that he requires a
congressional exemption to even be
allowed to be secretary of defense
let me explain that many people may not
know about this
there's a law the national security act
of 1947
which requires any prospective cabinet
secretary
to wait seven full years after ending
active duty in the military as a
commissioned officer
before you can be in a president's
cabinet lloyd austin was on active duty
until 2016.
now i am not going to be a hypocrite i
remember
that back in 2017 i did a story about
donald trump's secretary of defense
selection jim mattis uh at the time the
the title of this video was these
democrats
plus one republican had the balls to
vote no on trump cabinet now the title
doesn't tell you about what's in the
story
but in that story i explained jim mattis
trump's pick for secretary of defense
hasn't been out of active duty for seven
years
so congress is going to need to issue a
waiver to get jim mattis
in donald trump's cabinet and at the
time i said
why the hell do we have a rule about
this if the president can just go to
congress and get a waiver
and i'm not a hypocrite so i have to
tell you the exact same thing today
if we have this rule from 1947
why not stick to it what is the point if
joe biden can just get it waived
why do we need such a recent active duty
military person as secretary of defense
because the rule was meant to
disincentivize choosing
recent active duty military people
instead of choosing long-retired
military folks
or straight-up civilians for secretary
of defense the idea
being non-military secretaries of
defense
or or those who have a military
background but have been out of the
military longer
would be less cozy with the military and
they would bring
a more uh uh impartial approach
to sort of counterbalance the joint
chiefs of staff and others within the
military that's the whole point here
so this was a great opportunity for joe
biden to instead of starting with
another military officer who's was was
in the military so recently that he's
got to be waved in
joe biden could have started his
presidency with a return to normalcy
with civilian oversight of military
plans and actions
but he's the first black secretary of
defense that is the story that is being
told
and then on the other side of this
you're also putting a ton of democrats
in a really stupid looking position
because many democrats who will vote on
this
nomination opposed the waiver
for jim mattis in 2017. now
they are likely going to have to
acquiesce and okay
lloyd austin and this applies to those
in the house of representatives as well
confirming that they are hypocrites and
giving republicans more ammunition than
we need to give them to quote joe biden
come on man
this is misguided and then when you look
specifically at lloyd austin's military
career
it's not good lloyd austin was the
commanding general
in iraq and then commander of us central
command centcom in the u.s withdrawal
in 2011 the subsequent collapse of the
iraqi army in 2012 to isis
so now look at the big picture not only
are you having to wave in a guy too
recently in the military to be
traditionally
eligible you have a guy who during his
confirmation hearings
is going to be on the receiving end of
legitimate
criticisms for how he handled iraq as
well
so sadly there are people who are going
to listen to my entire story
and they're going to say david that's
racist you don't want a black secretary
of defense no
that's not what i said if you're going
to eat don't even email me
that don't even bother emailing me that
and unfortunately
we will lose subscribers we will lose
paid members because i did this story
because some people will not focus on
what i'm actually criticizing here
which is that we are diversifying in
terms of identity
but perpetuating the exact problems
that we've been pointing out for more
than a decade at this point in time so
so far nira tandon disastrous pick
uh lloyd austin very problematic for the
reasons that i mentioned these strike me
as unforced errors
if i'm missing something about this pick
let me know we'll have more coverage of
this
on our instagram at david pakman show
and
um i look forward to hearing your
thoughts
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently checked out the
book podcast marketing strategy by
daniel rowles
and kieran rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what i'm
doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video